faux dans la lutte contre colo vide
contre le coffee d'avoir une stratégie
et arrêter de faire de la communication
la stratégie c'est des tests massif
partout il compterait l'école c'est des
ffp2 dans les transports en commun ce
sont des vents des ventilations et de
l'aération des bâtiments pas seulement
les écoles mais partout par exemple le
gouvernement fédéral allemand a mis sur
la table 500 millions d'euros 1 2
milliard d'euros pour la ventilation des
bâtiments où est cet argent ou à cette
stratégie en france nous n'avons pas de
stratégie de lutte contre le cockpit
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre oui on
attend d'être face à un mur pour prendre
des décisions c'est dramatique un mot
sur les nouveaux actionnaires il
faudrait qu'ils soient vaccinés il
faudrait recréer un lien de confiance
avec eux c'est pas en disant à quelqu'un
que c'est un imbécile ou que ce n'est
pas un citoyen que vous allez recréer
quelque chose l'épidémie de covin c'est
aussi une crise de gouvernance si vous
voulez me valérie pécresse qu'est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle montre
aujourd'hui elles montrent que la droite
est de retour il ya encore quelques
semaines nous pensions que enfin
beaucoup de gens disaient la droite ne
va pas y arriver la preuve elle est
incapable d'avoir eu un ou une candidate
voilà maintenant un candidat avec une
union autour d'elle ce qui est certain
c'est valérie pécresse l'a sol gelé du
tout à leur personne qui est capable de
battre emmanuel macron elle doit se
mettre dans une posture ce qu'elle fait
de dire de dénoncer le quinquennat
catastrophique des manuels macron quand
je dis le quinquennat en réalité ça fait
dix ans qu'ils sont au pouvoir jean
rappelle qu emmanuel macron avec
ministre et conseiller du président de
la république rowland aujourd'hui les
présidents de la république qu'il ya dix
ans d'un quinquennat d'abandon vous
disiez le karcher bah oui mais sauf que
le kärcher on en a besoin on a besoin du
retour d'une droite avec de l'autorité
ou à l'autorité en france ont été tout
va à vau l'eau ce qu'on veut c'est
reprendre le contrôle
je vous ai parlé de la situation
sanitaire elle a parlé de la situation
sécuritaire le point commun de tout cela
c'est que la france actuellement et sans
contrôle nous voulons reprendre le
contrôle